hey 42 here you can do some pretty
amazing things with Sal fight wars heal
people even kill people we'll get more
into that in a minute but first can an
opera singer really shatter a wine glass
with their voice have you ever done this
the sound being emitted from the glass
is what's known as its resonant
frequency
that's the pitch at which an object
emits sound when affected by a physical
object every object has a different
resonant frequency it's easier to hear
the resonance from a wineglass because
it's unique Bowl shape amplifies the
sound so how can an opera singer use
this knowledge to shatter the glass
sound is essentially the compression and
rarefaction of the air around the source
creating pressure waves
that's why sound can't be heard in a
complete vacuum because there's no air
molecules to affect when you sing you
create these pressure waves on the air
around you however if you sing at the
exact same pitch or frequency that the
wineglass resonates at you will start to
create pressure waves around the glass
um if you sing loud enough and long
enough you can't shatter the glass but
it will require a lot of one power and
since opera singers excel in this field
they're the most likely to shut a glass
with their voice okay so you can
obliterate objects with your voice
that's impressive but you can do some
even more amazing things with sound
sound can actually be weaponized the
long range acoustic device is a sound
spotlight capable of emitting a beam of
sound at a target hundreds of meters
away up to 150 decibels it's used for
crowd control such as braking of riots
however they're also used on European
cruise ships to ward off Somali pirates
sound has also been recognized on a
smaller scale to take on all those
stubby teenagers running amok
the mosquito is an anti anti social
behavior device this small speaker can
be attached to the front of shops
railway lines and anywhere else you
don't want those little rascals
loitering about the speaker emits an
annoying high-pitched sound at 17
kilohertz because our hearing the great
of 8 the mosquitos high-frequency sound
waves can only be heard by teenagers
thus keeping them well clear of your
property a similar yet less obnoxious
approach to fighting minor crime was
taken in London when people hear music
they don't like their dopamine
production is suppressed in 2003 subway
stations in London started to play
classical music and it worked within a
year and a half
robberies and vandalism dropped by a
third for how dangerous can sound get
well theoretically it's possible to kill
someone with sound albeit rather
indirectly when a bomb explodes the
sudden rise in atmospheric pressure
creates what's called blast overpressure
resulting in an incredibly loud noise
being emitted over a large area
you won't hear the noise because your
eardrums shatter at 160 decibels
but at 200 decibels the sound pressure
will be enough to rupture along and
cause fatal internal injuries this
caused confusion in World War 1 when
soldiers were found dead despite having
no external injuries this means that all
those films you see where the
protagonist gets thrown from a massive
explosion unsurvivable own would kill
them however when controlled sound
pressure can be used to heal people a
high intensity focused ultrasound
transducer is a device that can focus
sound energy to such intense levels that
it creates heat similar to how kids burn
ants with a magnifying
the device can heat up an area as small
as a grain of rice to hundreds of
degrees in one study it was able to seal
the punctured lungs of pigs in just two
minutes this new technology means that
surgery could be performed without
making any incisions on the body or
using general anesthesia and patient
will be able to go home the same day
furthermore it can be used to cure
cancer by using their high food device
to heat up and kill the cancer cells the
technology was tested on 159 men with
prostate cancer and after one year 92%
of them did not have recurrent cancer
surprisingly
you can actually eliminate noise by
adding more noise noise cancellation
headphones work on this exact premise
they have a tiny microphone on their
periphery that constantly monitors all
noise outside your headphones usually
this noise will have a distinct waveform
of peaks and troughs the earphones
internal circuitry creates a new wave
form that has peaks and troughs exactly
opposite to the recorded noise and plays
it back into your ear this is called an
anti phase the anti phase cancels out
the background noise and all you hear is
your music it may seem like a strange
concept that's adding more noise can
remove it completely but it's like
having minus 2 and adding 2 you end up
with nothing the company has designed a
system that uses this technology in
restaurants and bars to cancel out the
noisy background drone of customers it
uses an array of over a hundred
microphones and speakers concealed
behind paintings around the venue the
microphones record the noise of the
customers and then creates an anti-phase
which it then plays back to the
customers via the speaker's cancelling
out the ambient noise this lets people
converse with each other without having
to raise their voices but if the venue
is mostly empty
it can also pump background noise out of
the speak
to make the place seem busier than it
actually is however the entire system
can cost up to $100,000 to install can
you guess where the quietest place on
earth is it's a small room in Salford
Manchester more specifically the UH
Nakoa chamber at the University of
Salford it's actually a room within a
room suspended in air by Springs and
lime with cross-hatched buffers that
absorb all sound the room absorbs 99.9%
of all sound it's so quiet that you can
hear your own internal organs and the
blood pumping through your veins the
chamber is used for testing low level
noise such as the home of a libel what
ironically most people find the place
upsetting no matter where you are
there's always a considerate amount of
background noise and our brains are very
accustomed to it the presence of noise
tells our body that things are working
however if you remove all sounds then
all your senses heighten and your body
goes into panic mode on 911 despite
having no mobile phone reception a huge
number of hikers mysteriously abandoned
their wolves they hadn't heard anything
about terrorist attacks their brains
would you're spooked by the lack of
aeroplane noise and they knew something
was wrong after five minutes in the
chamber you start to notice the smallest
sounds such as your scalp moving across
your skull when you frown and your heart
pounding in your chest
staying in the chamber for longer than
15 minutes can cause extreme symptoms
such as nausea and panic attacks most
people suffer aural hallucinations this
is when you start hearing sounds that
aren't even there everything from
scraping metal to voices apparently
nobody can survive 45 minutes in the
room without going insane but for some
unfortunate individuals sorts of real
experiences
an everyday occurrence superior canal
dehiscence syndrome is a rare medical
condition affecting the inner ear
it amplifies all internal sounds
sufferers hear their own heartbeat
creaking joints and other unsavory
internal bodily functions it can get so
bad that the sound of the eyeballs
moving in their sockets
sounds like quoting quote sandpaper on
wood sound travels at 761 point 2 miles
per hour at sea level but what happens
when you travel faster than the speed of
sound you experience what's called a
sonic boom which is an extremely loud
thumping sound it also creates a visual
phenomena called a mock coat this
happens because when an object travels
through the air it creates a series of
pressure waves in front and behind it
similar to how a boat displaces the
water the faster the object travels the
more that the pressure waves are
compressed together because they can't
get out of the way of each other fast
enough once you reach 761 miles per hour
otherwise known as Mach 1 the pressure
you've created reaches a critical mass
creating a shockwave but you won't hear
anything at all because you're traveling
faster than the speed of sound so the
sound will never reach your ears unless
you slow down but everyone on the ground
will hear thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2
you